hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
one year ago player unknowns
battleground moved over to console but
only for Xbox users as at the time it
was a timed exclusive for the platform
to put it kindly
the initial Xbox release saw a shocking
amount of technical issues only two
months ago
IGN deemed the Xbox one version of pub G
reliable enough to review and to be fair
the original version was classed as
early access anyway they gave it an
eight point nine out of ten now in
December 2018 pub G is finally coming to
ps4 so let's break it down everybody on
the globe by now knows the premise of
battle royale games 100 people skydive
onto a deserted map which constantly
shrinks until one person survives and is
crowned victorious or in pub G I should
say winner winner chicken dinner
there are duo's and squad variants too
if you prefer to fill the tension of
combat with company as I cover a great
deal of batarangs here on PlayStation
grenade I wanted to quickly outline the
core differences between fortnight and
pub G so as early as possible you know
which one is better for you
fortnight favors family friendly cartoon
characters and world whereas pub G is
going for realism of course the most
obvious difference in pub G is the
absence of building options making mad
dash across an open field feel like a
life-or-death scenario we can't simply
place a wall for cover a key difference
to know is the lack of numbers depicting
damage in pub G at no point do you truly
know the health of the opposition this
plays into the core difference player
unknowns battlegrounds is a tactical
shooter a slow-paced to tactical shooter
that somehow push is a typical player to
avoid conflict in favor of obtaining the
best spot on the map kind of the
opposite of fortnight where any position
can be fortified with building options
one final key difference is the weaponry
knowledge needed in pub G as scopes and
stocks are found littered throughout the
world giving players customisation
options
unavailable in fortnight so although
both games are of the same genre they
are most definitely different and
attract different players one of the key
battles when choosing a new shooter for
many people is deciding which viewpoint
they prefer third-person our first
person in the Battle Royale genre
fortnight is third-person
and block up fours blackout mode uses
first person
well pub G has a trick up its sleeve as
it offers both perspectives so if you
want to play from the eyesight of your
character it's your choice or maybe like
me you prefer to see your character and
whatever visual customization they are
wearing like this Last of Us backpack
but we'll get to that very soon
Bob G on ps4 comes with all current maps
the iconic a wrangle or is that her
angel I honestly have never heard
someone say out loud so I'm not sure
what would you call it anyway a wrangle
is the og map with the prison a hospital
and military base multiple towns and
villages and remains the community's
most beloved map to date the second map
is Miramar its pub G's desert inspired
map and make spotting falls far easier
forcing players to change strategies to
come out victorious the third map on
offer is Sun Hawk core as it's an HOH
Dallas I need help with that one to
sanho is a jungle map and once again
plays completely different from the
others the forest is dense and staying
unseen is far easier and ultimately a
better strategy the kicker to this
environment is the map is about 50%
smaller than the other two maps making
confrontations far more often and offers
a faster play style let's look into the
future for a moment player unknowns
battlegrounds has a fourth map incoming
very soon very very soon if the
pre-order information is true a snow
themed map named Vic nd is almost here
not much is known about this new area
but with the northern hemisphere hitting
the winter holiday period now would be a
great time to drop the content and
attract more players should you want
access to weekend e on the day releases
you'll need the survivors edition of pub
G but don't worry we'll break down those
very soon we're going to get technical
just for a few seconds for gamers to
feel smooth and responsive in video
games the frame rate of 60 FPS is the
benchmark or the holy grail on console
fortnight achieve this this year and
black ops for almost achieve 60 frames
per second in blackout mode due to the
graphical intensities of pub G and by
using the Xbox one as a precursor it's
highly unlikely the ps4 version of pub G
will run at 60 frames per second to be
completely honest 30 frames per second
will be a chore for the standard ps4 I
think you should be aware of that but
I'm not here to be the bringer of bad
news
multiple times Pub G devs have stated
their ultimate goal is to achieve
stability at 60 frames per second on all
platforms and from that we can guarantee
continued updates if we look forward to
January and some people have said it may
even happen this month we are getting
the addition of ranked matches kind of
similar to the approach that overwatch
takes new graphical options on console
will be added soon - such as field of
view when aiming down scopes and of
course new weapons are always on the way
such as the Scorpion do in the new
update plus we've already talked about
the snow map imminently arriving to the
future looks bright indeed oh and get
this there's even talk of a Capcom
crossover allowing Resident Evil
characters to jump into battlegrounds
Leon and Claire in duo's yes please so
now is the right time to talk about
price yes pub G is not free to play
games like fortnight and h1z1 have
caused many people to believe Battle
Royale is a freebie
it isn't but it also isn't a full priced
game like black ops 4 in the UK pub G
launches at 25 pounds and in the US
that's $30 so about half the price of a
standard triple-a game and when does it
all start on Friday the 7th of December
this week in fact should you preorder
the game there are a few bonuses which
look incredible to any dedicated
PlayStation gamer uncharted and the Last
of Us have skin options in pub G Nathan
Drake iconic outfit is available but the
thing which I'm most excited about is
this backpack from the Last of Us this
was Ellie's and if you played through
The Last of Us
this will certainly pull on your
heartstrings of course on day one the
problem is everyone will be wearing
these items on top of this there's also
the usual avatar and Static ps4 themes
to pick up do by looking at those
aesthetic items you probably already
figured out pub G has a bottle pass
feature just like fog Knights the
currency used to acquire these items are
BP and G coins BP our battle points
which are earned in-game and go towards
good old cosmetic items G coins on the
other hand are pretty similar but they
can only be bought with real money
purchases but yet again they are solely
here for cosmetic items this game offers
no pay2win mechanics which leads me on
to my final point versions of the game
like every game nowadays there are so
many versions it can be a mine for you
trying to understand them pubsey on ps4
has four iterations the first two are
the disc Edition for those people who
actually want to physically own the game
and the leutis Edition which is
identical but completely digital there's
also the survivors Edition which offers
the survival pass or battle pass if you
prefer for the snow map coming soon that
Edition comes with some of the in-game
currencies we've talked about enough to
buy a few high-level visual items and
finally the champions edition is
identical to that yet offers even Margy
coins for epic level cosmetics stand out
from the crowd we all love to do it we
can't help ourselves Oh anyway we did it
so there we have it ten things I believe
you need to know before playing player
unknown battleground which kicks off on
ps4 on December 7th if you're still
unsure about this game I'll be back with
gameplay on Friday I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a bloody
pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]